bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vigenti oggi siamo tornati
su the strange adventures of good day to
die anche per prenderlo nei cup laser i
cani devo fare come faccio non è normale
sta cosa
muoio non è possibile ma fermi che non
ho capito devo saltare sopra me stesso
c'è sempre qualcosa che non va per forza
adesso calmissimi che per mio dio a
[ __ ] lo sapevo che qualcosa non andava
sì se ciò fatta non pensavo di riuscirci
così facilmente perfetto da cani che
adesso checkpoint 15 a faccio perché se
una scarpa non l'ho capita sta cosa però
va beh lo sa per lo sapeva perché io so
le cose migliorano che ha adesso
succederà può saltare prima della scarpa
di sicuro lo sa ma tv ne so io le cose
le so prima che succedano prima che
muoia uguale cosa ho fatto regalo non so
neanch'io le scarpe mi stanno sul culo a
io ve lo dico già rainforest random
prenderle le prendo le prendo prese le
rane scarpe da corsa fuori lurido
fiammelle di merda una nè un cammello
nager sì lo so che ti ho ferito nei
sentimenti ma che ho fatto prima fare
sta parte che non l'ho capita così no
così un cazzo regalo capi come fermati
luri ma ancora faccio questa parte come
cosa devo cliccare non so se sono io ma
certe cose faccio fatica a capirle
proprio camere non so ditemelo
magari andiamo a prendere le scarpe
domanda non devo prendere
ok non erano sia non dovevo prendere le
scarpe fantastico tanto so che c'era
qualche trappola vinto il me ne frega
una sega vabbè ma non l'ho studiato
musica non le so fare ste cose
ok
[Musica]
questo andava bene ragazzi però non ho
capito dopo cosa devo fare
a premere due volte questo si no due
volte basta 123 no non so un cazzo di
musica
ok ma [ __ ] è questa qua davanti se
si è fatta l'ultima l'ultima questa non
so che sono ignoranti in materia però
non è colpa mia se va a fan culo
si si si sente zheng ma va a cagare però
devo prenderla no mi sono punto il dito
sai 2da lo infilo adesso faccio tutto un
casino e poi è sbagliato e giustamente
ma ci mancherebbe ok
cosa devo fare ad è come ci arrivo si
copre è no e non va bene cosa cazzo
clicco tua madre sì se qualcuno adesso
questa mela spiega perché non ho capito
che sarà roba perché che calmi che mi si
è così diventa cos'è cos'è sta roba
no merda starò ma bellissimo ma
bellissimo una sega è diventato cari no
ok ok
strano no no no non ho toccato niente
orientato strada ci sono gli switch
adesso devo prenderesti tasti in tempo
re canina come cosa solo che non che non
ho pazienza se fosse più facile ma porca
la merda che più avanti vado più mi
chiedo che cazzo ci sto ancora facendo
giusto gioco però non penso di avere non
penso che avrò mai la risposta
ok ok la pistola cos'è una roba tipo
james bond fantastico bello bello però
non è solo morto uguale di toccarli
scommettono
non l'ho mancata di banana che mira
brutta che ciò che dovete morire
dovete morire come faccio da solo anzi
zag sto schifo non è che va dritto no ci
mancherebbe che andasse dritto anche ci
mancherebbe poiché per che bella faccia
salti zio e bellissima veloce
no no no io sono un [ __ ] che manca i
tasti o no per un click
ok ok va bene così perfetto non mi
lamento grazie mille cioè la mamma viene
normal bridges di stupidi game ci sono
beni punti normali in questo stupido
gioco no perché è un gioco di merda è
tutto il contrario adesso perfetto no
grandi schiaffi a chi ha creato gioco
no no no no proprio devi capire che se
sei stupido che allora calmi calmi
ok ok ok perfetto no no orca ladra
difficilissimo regali ma perché poi tra
l'altro fantastico perfetta adesso ce la
faccio però è ok
se sì l'ho preso mi sembra non so perché
quando principe poi in sembra che mi
stiano prendono per il culo sosta
sensazione ogni volta tipo questa adesso
perfetto perfetto che il primo è andato
cosa dove devo incazzarmi di preciso
adesso danger seif ovviamente io vado
nel danger perché mi devo morire come un
[ __ ] devo morire
lo so che devo andare in mano fermi ok
perfetto lancio sto coso veloce sì sì ok
kami ragazzo ha fatto sì ok adesso mi
deve rompere i [ __ ] lo so lo so che
faccia di merda poi l'ici salto sopra
vedi questi infilo tutti e due ce l'ho
fatta ragazza l'ha fatta di moda ecco
ancora come pensano di prendermi per il
culo evidentemente sì adesso devo
veramente farli fuori tutti in tempo non
ce la faccio troppo poco tempo zio come
adesso non va più bene
c'è prima avevo sparato su cosa adesso
non mi fa più sparare fantastico cosa no
fermi non ci posso che no dai veramente
gelido premere con la col dito devono
premere seacom ma [ __ ]
adesso adesso no no no no no no no no
camere fascino quasi veloce veloce sì sì
ho vinto ho vinto cos'è sto schifo ci
mancava al colosso proprio ok ok ok ok
premi veloce ok fuori dai cazzo giova ho
vinto ho vinto vita adesso vinto adesso
vinto c'è gloria ragazzi ce la porta 2
human to play the game
che cazzo ci fa l'enigmista quale one to
play game i più sentiti ora sto già
giocando il gioco di merda non tc
mettere anche turche sopraffare bello mi
piace suo livello è pieno di significato
di basta cos'è s'è fermato se ho vinto
ho vinto nono vinto [ __ ] mi
sembrava di sembrava troppo bella e rega
che è l'ultimo che poi sto morendo basta
non ne posso più uno fatto ocse ma
questa la tendina ma [ __ ] con la
catenina del ipad romoli uguale rega
highlights smart people all'ascolto zio
a me piace tua sorella ok quindi
capiamoci in ogni devo morire
c'è un caso che spunta in basso che non
ho capito che cos'è
ok sì sì sì ma mai aires mal people
[Musica]
io santo siamo nel 2040 hanno giocato 26
anni a sto potuto gioco per arrivare fin
qua gift from milan guarda zia non ci ho
proprio voglia di continuare adesso sono
morto è stato bellissimo proprio gioco
bello ragazzi concluso qui perché e sta
veramente sto gioco esasperante è a dir
poco veramente comunque ragazze il viso
è piaciuto commons lasciate un commento
mi piace anche a pagina di facebook e
con i video tratte alla descrizione
rischi discreta mi ci invidiavano
prossimo video belle ragazze